[Musik]
das gesamtnetz willkommen bei einem
neuen video leute ohne spaß das ist das
schönste video ever elfer aber
eigentlich müsste ich schlecht drauf
sein
aber an sich ist wirklich ganz lustig
und zweitwagen der standard und termin
die fans bald wieder kommen wir hatten
hier noch besuch wegen gamescom video
oder sonst was die waren bis heute hier
ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gleich nach
hause fahren mit meinem auto kann man es
dreckig und ich bin jetzt gerade
untergegangen mit den anderen und das
ist echt was krasses passiert also es
ist auch der einsätze schon lustig ich
bin mal gespannt ob wir das gleich alles
wieder weg räumen können und ich muss
euch das jetzt einfach mal zeigen weil
ich euch mein auto so eigentlich nicht
vorenthalten möchte ich meine so ein
autohof eingepackt sieht man auch nicht
alle tage
und die haben da glaube ich auch
ziemlich lange gesessen deswegen gehen
wir jetzt mal runter und ich bin
gespannt was wir jetzt mit dem ganzen
zeug machen
ich dachte wirklich am anfang erst heute
das jetzt nicht euer ernst weil ich habe
wirklich angst gehabt dass als kassel
raus so oder so ich weiß zwar noch nicht
an ich gehe nicht davon aus aber das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal ein woran ich
mein auto ist wirklich nicht
wiederzuerkennen ok seid ihr bereit 321
ja nicht gleich was da hat das ist
karbon alles natürlich gesorgt
bundesliga fast nur auf die haben das
auto mit 160 meter alufolie eingewickelt
naja wie kommt man auf so ne du hast es
verdient du es zwei wochen eine pizza
bei uns in der wohnung liegen lassen
hastig kam wieder nicht so meine eltern
kamen ich so jung dass auch darauf nicht
die wohnung sauber und demnach habe
extra noch aufgaben ich gehe die wohnung
wirklich fünf pizzakarton hatten wir
liegen im bodenbereich alles voll mit
eistee flaschen und spaß wenn jetzt
kratzer drauf sind
ich weiß ja wie gefällt sie nicht
geblitzt wenn wir das besser gefällt als
die schöne schwarz macht nur die tür auf
und sticht damit korrekt ich fahre damit
ich damit der hunger nicht auf die
straße gehen der tiefgarage machen also
noch ein fachmann noch ein
außerdem ich sehe nicht mal was ich habe
nicht mal nicht mal im spiegel kann ich
was sehen
hey wie viele wie viele schichten sind
das bitte erläutert so ein kind das hat
gesagt guck mal die an meinem auto okay
wir fahren das man aber ich kann doch
gar nichts sehen
[Musik]
aachen
leute guckt mal wie dunkel die man sieht
ja einfach gar nichts drin ok warte
warte ich mal machen die alle polen
voraus buchen
ich sehe einfach gar nichts in der
rückfahrkamera machen manchmal die
alufolie zum ausdruck bringt leute ich
sehe gar nichts mehr
manchmal kann ich geradeaus fahren ihr
müsst aber sagen wo ich langsam hierher
kannst du kannst noch verfügbar
denn dafür
gibt noch einmal gas dann ist alles weg
ich will das gefühl haben dass auf jeden
fall ein daumen nach oben da und auf
jeden fall mehr leute ich war doch mal
bei sony verbaut so meinte ich habe
meine jugend dabei hat sie ganz da
hinkommen wo leute bereits sechsmal
größer wenn jeden fall drin ist ist
erstmal das konzept
ich jetzt hier alufolie drin
die jungs hätten hätte ich nicht mal
sagen können dass wir jetzt hier ist
jetzt alles voll mit alufolie mein gott
also häufig war das interview nie vorbei
heißt es in der beschreibung war ich bin
mega spontanes video
ich glaube ich muss mir doch etwas mehr
einfallen lassen für den kleinen menge
und jetzt sieht das aus dieser schönen
haus auf jeden fall
wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen kommt
das video haut rein müssen das jetzt
hier weg vorbei sind kriegen wir ärgern
uns diesmal haben wir machen hier